I have just genuinely good news for you
today
last week I reported to you that in the
midterm elections Republican martha
mcsalley won against democratic
congresswoman Kyrsten Sinema that has
changed since election night they've
been counting uncounted ballots which
you should do if the ballots are valid
and as it turns out those uncounted
ballots were disproportionately from the
blue parts of Arizona and cinema took
what is now an insurmountable lead and
has defeated Republican martha mcsalley
mcsalley
conceding so Republicans will still
control the Senate with a majority but
by one fewer or is it one less seat or
one fewer seat than we thought in either
case they're going to have not as many
seats as they believed they were going
to have and very interestingly when it
comes to Kyrsten Sinema specifically
number one the last time that Arizona
even had a Democratic senator was in
1995 with Dennis Deacon Cheney and that
that is notable also notable that
Kyrsten Sinema she appears to be the
first US senator elected who formally
says she has no religious affiliation
and we can all sort of understand that
there were there were and are very
likely some senators who are not
actually religious but they still say I
am Christian statistically speaking or
maybe I am Jewish in the case of some so
this is not literally the first
non-religious person but it is the first
senator who formally states that she is
not part of any organized religion and
this is why you've got to fight every
race and count every ballot if we had
accepted Pat on election day that this
was it and not continued to push she
might not have won
we now have updated midterm results it's
good for Democrats and this is why we
have to make sure that every single
ballot Pat is counted in Florida because
it might not change the results
but it might yeah and Kyrsten Sinema
she's not the most progressive person
out there but hey it is Arizona after
all and I'd rather see a Democrat win
that seat than a Republican and it looks
like the the Republican majority in the
Senate is gonna be 53 to 47 that makes
it slightly easier for Democrats to take
back the Senate in 2020 that road now
becomes a lot more possible and I want
to talk about in the context of 2020 so
last week when I gave sort of my
analysis of the results which were this
was pretty good for Democrats given the
circumstances but at the same time I
understand wanting more because we have
such an outrageous administration right
now and I get it when you see this
cartoonish disaster that we have in the
White House right now you think wow if
people understand what's going on we
should be absolutely crushing and we had
a situation where the Senate was stacked
against us
just slightly losing really isn't that
bad when you consider that in the House
Democrats have as of right now picked up
32 seats this may not be the
overwhelming victory some wanted but the
truth is that this is the most seats
that Democrats have picked up in a
midterm election in any election in the
house in a very long time I don't even
remember exactly when when the last time
was that Democrats had plus 32 in an
election in the house but this is a good
result the the Democrats won the popular
vote in the House by five million votes
they won the popular vote in the Senate
by about 14 million if I recall
correctly and if you account for the
fact that for dianne feinstein's seat
you had two Democrats running you can
take away all of Kevin de Leon's votes I
think it was about two and a half three
million you still have Democrats
receiving 11 million more votes in
Senate races than Republicans so there
is now a very clear set of goals for
2020 the Senate is going to be tough
even though the map is in some ways
better for Democrats in the Senate in
2020 because Democrats are going to have
more safe seats than Republic
the Republican seats as pat pointed out
last week are mostly in some pretty red
states you're almost definitely i think
pat going to lose alabama back to
republicans you had a serial child sex
assault or who only lost by a few points
any reasonable person is Prabha and by
reasonable I mean not a serial accused
sex assault ur Democrats will probably
lose Alabama but there is a path to
controlling the Senate there that is
true Democrats will probably lose
Alabama but hey they can probably beat
Cory Gardner in Colorado they might be
able to beat Joni Ernst in Iowa Thom
Tillis he's vulnerable in North Carolina
and Susan Collins our good old friend
from Maine I think she she could lose
that race as well so the point is you've
got to fight every seat you have to
fight for every vote and until all the
votes are actually counted you aren't
done and we will see what we ultimately
hear about the recounts that are
currently taking place in Florida and
that's actually what I want to talk
about next today's show was made
possible in part by simple habit comm
slash Pakman at this point the benefits
of meditation have been pretty clearly
shown to be significant and that's why
I'm so excited that simple habit is
sponsoring the show which is a guided
meditation app that just won the 2018
Google Play award for best well-being
app I use the app myself all you need is
five to ten minutes a day simple habit
lets your brain go on a quick vacation
that it very likely really needs maybe
you've been thinking about giving
meditation a try you don't know where to
start simple habit is really the perfect
way to just jump right into it great for
beginners equally useful for people with
meditation experience they've got quick
meditations for first thing in the
morning for falling asleep at night for
clearing your mind when you're stressed
meditations for decision-making for
getting motivated getting focused
getting creative hundreds and hundreds
to choose from they're designed and
recorded by well-known names in the
world of meditation and mindfulness and
you can track all of your progress so
whatever time of day it is whatever mood
you're in there's probably a meditation
on simple habit
that's perfectly suited for whatever
you're trying to accomplish with
meditation go check it out you can try
it free for seven days at simple habit
calm slash Pakman I've put a link
underneath this video